here's something interesting and also
kind of sad
CNBC's Joe Kernan attacked me as a
socialist on Twitter the other day and
this actually relates to a bigger
picture thing that's going on when I was
15 years old I started paying attention
to political news and business news and
financial news and I started investing a
little bit of the money I earned Circuit
City where I worked in in high school I
started watching CNBC and CNN and
reading newspapers and political
magazines and reading old investing
books by Ben Graham and by others and
just learning about this stuff and in
doing that I got to know a lot of who
the news people were at the time and
sadly now is an adult who's working in
news media I've gotten a chance to meet
or interact directly with a lot of these
people and I am so disillusioned with a
lot of them that I can't believe that I
ever thought that they had great things
to contribute but when I was a kid I
mean maybe they did at the time so like
one example is I never met her in person
but I used to respect Maria Bartiromo
okay when Maria Bartiromo was on CNBC
she was the first woman to report from
the floor of the stock exchange very
interesting I saw her as a strong
interviewer who would confront corporate
CEOs with tough questions and deliver
financial news in a business that was so
dominated by men at the time she now has
a show at Fox Business Network
has completely jumped on board the Trump
sycophant brown-noser train and she
truly disgusts me like it's just sad
what has happened to Maria Bartiromo
someone else that I used to admire who I
now know personally and I'm hugely
disillusioned with is scott adams the
creator of the Dilbert cartoon when I
was growing up I loved the Dilbert
comics I read all of them I read some of
Scott Adams books I thought that the
comics were hilarious in terms of being
commentaries about corporate culture I
found the books interesting I've now
interviewed Scott Adams multiple times
sometimes we direct message privately on
Twitter and as I've told him publicly
it's become a huge disappointment I mean
a childhood disillusionment to see him
become this staunch defender of Donald
Trump really really sad and there's now
another person we can add to this list
list and his name is Joe Kernan from
CNBC
Kernan has been on CNBC yes since I was
a fifteen year old and started watching
Business News he's a guy in his early
60s who's been with CNBC since 1991 I
don't want to pretend he was ever a hero
of mine but similarly to to Maria
Bartiromo I grew up watching him
interview corporate CEOs and the whole
thing and I already started to look at
Joe Kernan very skeptically when he was
on a panel interview with a former
Facebook executive a year or two ago and
he was asking like the dumbest and most
uninformed questions about social media
and social networks and I thought man
Joe Kernan might have no clue what the
hell he's talking about and it is now
much worse because over the weekend in
late last week he got into an argument
about whether CNBC is now jumping on the
climate science denying train because of
an interview that he did related to
climate science or something I ended up
getting tagged into this Twitter thread
about it and Joe Kernan tweeted
something so ridiculous about carbon
dioxide which has become a popular
talking point on the science denying
right that carbon dioxide is great
because plants need it to breathe we
breathe out co2 and plants breathe in
co2 so more co2 is great for plants
which of course ignores all of the
science around this and it ignores the
idea of an ecosystem imbalance in the
same way that listen humans need water
in order to live but at a certain point
too much water becomes bad for us right
the same sort of logic applies to carbon
dioxide so then Joe Kernan shows up and
tweets in this thread that I'm in you do
know humans exhale 100 times the
concentration of atmospheric co2 ever
had a coke
be careful laced with poison which is
just so dumb and I responded damn to
think I used to watch Joe on CNBC when I
was a kid growing up depressing and sort
of surprisingly joke Hernan responded to
me and said yet you still grew up to be
a silly millennial socialist that is
depressing which of course is number one
using a socialist
and insults but more importantly I am
NOT a socialist which I told them saying
hey Joe I'd love for you to present one
shred of evidence that I'm a socialist
and of course I never heard back so when
this stuff happens yeah like it's
depressing on a personal level to see
these people out themselves as toxic
fact free science denying ideologues and
it's also just depressing that I used to
actually look up to some of these people
not ideologically but in terms of their
kind of place and role in the media
sphere and some very basic sense and it
turns out that they are truly horrible
people contributing to the weaponization
of ignorance that has become endlessly
prevalent in the era of Trump so I guess
someone someone else on the list that
now is going to be seen very differently
by me and probably by much of my
audience although my guess is my
audience probably already had a far more
negative view of Joe Kernan that I did
before these tweets let me know what you
think make sure you're following the
show on instagram at david pakman show
and follow me on instagram at david
pakman